nous travaillons dans le noir servons la lumière hé les
gars mon argent - nous sommes des assassins le
film d'Assassin's Creed Je veux juste que
ce soit une balade incroyable qui
vous mène dans des séquences d'action
dynamiques et elles sont vraiment excitantes
et nous essayons  pour baser autant que
possible dans la réalité
je suis Dave ultis je suis distinct au-dessus de
Michael dans le film
le personnage de Michael Fassbender est piégé et il
doit sauter un acte de foi en
sautant 125 pieds normalement ce serait un
personnage numérique qui sauterait
Damien est le meilleur donc nous allons le
faire pour de vrai
Justin veut que ce soit aussi réel que
possible nous allons dans le monde réel
nous ne comptons pas sur les effets visuels nous
commençons bas avec le premier saut nous avons
juste une question  de déterminer le moment
de la chute libre, l'empreinte réelle
du bogue n'est que de 10 mètres sur 10 mètres,
donc lorsque vous êtes là-haut, il ressemble à peu près à la
taille d'un mauvais morceau de papier à la
verticale de 7
pieds de nouveau
dans la banque  top-lourd alors obtenez un peu avec
beaucoup  l'arrière de la tête alors essaie de
ne pas faire ça trois
à ce
que c'est le mieux quand tu
t'en vas je vais bien ouais
toi